你們當初的圖面可能沒有回路怎麼進來的? 雖然你那時候是代驗公司嗎?對不對?那驗公司應該有對過開關插座數量嗎? 呃開關數量我們現在其實問題不是在於數量是在於空管或者是回路 因為它上面是寫回路插座三檢可是他們的認知會覺得說我迴路還是要進去啊
那現在看要怎麼去
買房子迴路不用進去 那我這個房子要買好嗎?
不然你這個項目就要寫說 我什麼迴路刪掉
或者是你別戶 同一個戶型的 有哪些迴路 你要拿出來對
就算業主是白癡 你也要告訴業主說 你這是白癡做法 這個管沒有進去 那你應該要保留 就像你們上面有寫 你這個不能移位 那你不能移位 你都已經告訴我不能動了 那我如果做了白癡的事情 說你做的是白癡的事情 電進不去喔 你們有進到高度嗎 因為我們也不曉得 你到底有沒有量 量在哪裡 你們的配電箱是派外面是配在裡面?你們應該不會連量在哪裡都不知道?量沒有寫高度?你們提供的量只有量位沒有量的口味高度?你們覺得你們做的很到位嗎?我覺得我不敢說百分之百一定都有蔬師,這我不會否認,但是我覺得今天討論這東西有意義嗎?應該是解決問題吧? 解決問題不要責任您請因為剛才回歸回來就說圖簽了嘛 所以我們才就簽為這裡
所以一開始我們要來討論的就是 我租了這個房子 我怎樣是進到我裝修能夠做到給屋主一個舒適的家
但是現在的問題是 很少有戶型 四邊全部都是涼 現在光是空調沒有過去 因為成... 四邊都是涼的戶型 現在房子很正常嘛 四邊都是涼的 涼非常好 涼已經低到 我只剩下了 要有轉就不正常 四邊都是涼的房子很好 二十公分 你裝修跟東西怎麼配? 我進不去很快 我們現在不是走消防管嗎? 消防管 你們不同意 現在不是六個空管嗎? 到五個空管嗎?五個空管他們買的東西是要配在那個貝豆漿這是他們買的東西而且這是原本消防管現在應該預留是給消防的吧現在只是找不到地方要塞管跟他一起走當然啊現在不就是解決嗎 你的意思是不要走這裡 一定要打結構
沒有人說打結構這是你們要想辦法解決 現在說我給你幾個方案好
你打地上這個磁磚重鋪 這個都是你們的方式 對吧 你不一定要去打結構
好不好 自己去討論 你跟我們講你們要怎麼解決?所以我們可能會覺得除了這五的回路以外,應該會有進到室內的...
那要全部從前對過一輪站的訪問喔?
對不對?沒有錯嘛!
如果按照你們的意思就是怎樣?
那再來是,因為也不是說有問題就這樣,退錢等等,因為這不是解決問題,那解決問題的話,那就是可能是看像你們如果說本來應該是地板上沒有退掉的有幾個管進去或幾組回路進去,那這樣子應該要到至少沒有在結構體內,或者是至少到沒有退掉的點位,就是不是說要要凹你們你們的意思是因為如果回路是的確是沒有退掉
那當時因為像我不可靠
我這邊沒有辦法說什麼
那當時我們的屋主也認為是回路是有保留的話
那這樣是不是回路的部分可以至少進到室內
因為不然的話
好我們這邊如果說現在六支
那再塞塞塞,我覺得相信以正常這個頻數,然後現在大家用電量越來越多的狀況下,我們不太可能全部從電箱,就是從這個孔這樣子進到室內,那我們可以一起討論像,好,現在這樣,那又不要破壞結構題的話,我們可以怎麼一起解決這個問題?
一部分是權責,因為如果你們認為不是你們的問題,那當然你們可以提出,再來是解決問題嘛,一個是權責,一個是把事情解決掉如果這樣說我覺得先討論中間到底還差了些什麼再來討論怎麼解決先核對嗎對 先核對因為目前這樣定起來我們的建議方式有為你們看起來是不會介紹的